[موسيقى]
عائلات تحت ركام غرقه في البحار اشلاء
متناثره جثث متفحمه اجساد مغتصبه ومنك بها
قتل تعذيب في السجون وجوه جائعه اتجار
بالبشر عالمنا المعاصر يكاد يطفح بالكوارث
طبيعيه كانت ام مفتعله في كل ثانيه وفي كل
دقيقه يمكن ان نجد ماساه ما في مكان ما
تثير تعاطفنا
لكن لماذا يكون التعاطف سيلا عارما حينا
ويتحول الى لا مبالاه تامه في حين اخر هل
يمكن للمعاناه ان تكون محقه في حاله ما
وان يغضى النظر عنها في حالات اخرى ماذا
عن الضحايا هل نشفق عليهم بنفس الدرجه ام
ان هناك ضحيه تستحق ان نتعاطف معها اكثر
من غيرها التعاطف الانتقائي في فلك
الممنوع ضحايا ضحايا هيدي روح بالنهايه
وببدا هيدي روح يعني كان من هون ولا من
هون ونا اوتوماتيك مام قول فم مساوات انه
المساوات ما فماش مساوات تعاطف مع طفل
الطفل ده لو فلسطيني ما ذنبو اي حاجه ولو
برضو اسرائيلي ما زنبو اي حاجه اذا
اختلفنا في الديانه او او القوميه او
العرقيه ولكن يبقى انه تجمع ل الانسانيه
كله سواسي يعني كل الارواح بتموت وكلها بت
سواء صغير او طفل كبير او مراه او شو مكان
النوع كله سواسه يعني لازم نتعاطف مع الكل
ظالمين ما نجم ان نتعاطف معهم جمله مع
المظلومين والمسلمين كلهم اجمعين دول
الاسلام كله التعاطف هم ينقسم بين مثلا
ويا رجل كبير وامراه ويا صغير هيك راح
يكون يتقسم انه نعتبر هشي صار معنا او مع
اهلنا كل واحد فيهم له احلامه وقصصه
وحياته اشياء كان لسه بت يحققها مستحيل اي
انسان يتعاطف نفس التعاطف مع كل الناس الا
اذا يكونون الناس او المحيط اللي انت ب ما
يعنوا لك شي ممكن تتعاطف بنسبه ثابته لكن
اللي يعنوا لك لا كل الضحايا اكيد ضحايا
ضحايا وعرب كله بتعاطف مع كل الاطفال بس
يعني طبعا بتعاطف مع اطفال فلسطين اكثر
وغزه اكثر احنا متعاطف معهم كلهم كلهم مين
ما كان يكون لان هول الضحايا عم بموتوا
ماهم جنب بشي المفارقات السياسيه اللي طرت
على المجتمعات هي اللي وصلت الى هذا اللي
نشوفه احنا بغزه
وفرنسا بالعراق وكل دول العالم اللي هو
قتل البشر لا كل انسان مظلوم نحنا يعني
معه بس في ظلم عن ظلم بيفرق بينما يكون
يحاسبه المظلوم مثل الظالم هي مش منطق ولا
في منطق ولا في شي من ه الموضوع اي
التعاطف هو نفسه ما يكون ب نسبيه لان
الضحيه هو يبقى ضحيه مهما يكون جنسيته
لونه عرقه فهو يبقى ضحيه كلهم عباره عن
احلام عن اهداف بحياتهم عن عن حياه تاركين
عمليه التعاطف كل انسان عنده ضمير لازم
يتعاطف ويا
الكل
التعاطف الانتقائي في فلك الممنوع ابدا من
اليون عبر سكايب مع الكاتب والصحفي سمير
يوسف اهلا بك يا سمير حين تحدثنا عن موضوع
هذه الحلقه قلت لي انك تفكر في مساله
التعاطف الانتقائي منذ مده كيف تقارب هذا
الموضوع وهل تعتبر انك كانسان قادر على
التعاطف بشكل متساو مع كل ضحايا او كل
ضحيه مرحبا ميسلون مرحبا لجميع ضيوفك انا
بصراحه س تحدث اليوم يعني من موقعي ك
اعلامي كصحفي
ا ولكن ردا على سؤالك اولا طبعا انا يعني
مجبر كانسان لا لست مجبرا يعني ولكن
عاطفتي الانسانيه تدفعني الى التعاطف مع
الجميع من دون استثناء لان كما قال احد ال
الاشخاص في الروبورتاج الصغير الذي رايناه
انه وصلنا الى مرحله اصبح فيها دم البشر
رخيصا والكارثه اليوم التي يعني كانت
بعيده الى حد ما عن اوروبا اقتربت مع
الحرب الروسيه والازمات تتلاحق ولدينا هذا
الشعور الدائم بانها ستصل يعني الى حدود
بيتنا بالتالي نحن
يعني ليس ليس كرما وليست انسانيه منا ولكن
ايضا من منطق يعني ان يكون الانسان ذكيا
لا لا مش الخوف فقط منطق الذكاء البشري
يدفعنا لنرفض ما يجب رفضه وان نقول بصوت
اعلى ربما انه هون يا جماعه يجب ان ننتبه
لانه مضينا في طريق الى حد ما خاطئ واعتقد
ان هذا الانطباع ليس شخصيا فقط اعتقد ان
اذا انت تعتبر اننا نعيش في عصر يعني
تمارس
فيه يمارس فيه التعاطف الانتقائي طبعا
طبعا هذا الشي هذا الشيء واضح طبعا طيب
دعني اذهب الى البحرين عبر سكايب ايضا
الاكاديمي والكاتب الدكتور نادر كاظم اهلا
بك دكتور نادر كتبت
كثيرا في امور مختلفه طبعا ولكن كتبت ايضا
عن الكراهيه بشكل خاص عده اصدارات برايك
هل الكراهيه هي التي تؤثر على التعاطف لدى
الناس وتجعل منه
انتقائيا اه نعم بالتاكيد الكراهيه احد
العوامل يعني من حيث المبدا التعاطف في
ظني مشاعر انسانيه طبيعيه
وفي عباره لجان جا كروسو بانها القانون
الطبيعي الاول هو اللي يحفظ النوع البشري
اصلا يعني اذا اذا حب الذات يحفظ البشر
كافراد فالتعاطف هو القانون اللي يحفظ
النوع البشري بمعنى ان انت تشعر ب الم
الاخر لكن الحقيقه ان التعاطف مع
الاخرين مرتبط
بمساله لا دخل لها بالطبيعه البشريه مرتبط
بمساله المسافه او القرب والبعد ام بمعنى
الى اي درجه الشخص الاخر الذي يعاني
ويتالم
ويخسر الى اي درجه هو قريب مني ودرجه هو
بعيد عني القرب بالمعنى الجغرافي وبالمعنى
التخيلي بمعنى انني اشعر
بان الشخص الذي يموت امامي ويعاني ويتالم
ويحزن ويخسر
امامي درجه تعاطفي معه تكون اعلى من درجه
شخص اخر بعيد عني او لا اعرفه نعم طبعا في
كثير من الا ابحاث انعملت فيما يتعلق
بعلاقه التعاطف بالهويه الهويه الثقافيه
او الاجتماعيه ووجد في الفعل بال في
الابحاث بان هناك علاقه وثيقه بين التعاطف
وبين الهويه بمعنى ان البشر اكثر قدره على
التعاطف مع القريبين منهم والذين يشعرون
بانهم ينتمون لهم في الهويه الدينيه او
الاثنيه او
ا حتى المناطق الجغرافيه وانهم يشعرون
بدرجه اقل مع الذين يبتعدون عنهم في
الهويه لكن المشكله فيما يتعلق بالتعاطف
الانتقائي ليس في درجه التعاطف يعني هو
ليس هناك انت تشعر بدرجه ادنى او اقل مع
معاناه الاخرين وانما في وجود تعاطف عالي
بدرجه عاليه مع طرف وانعدام تعاطف مع طرف
اخر ولا مبالات تامه او حتى احيانا شماته
يعني احيانا حتى تشفي نوع من التشفي كانما
ما يحصر له من معاناه يستحقها ويستحق اكثر
نعم هو يتجاوز التعاطف والتشفي
ومافي والتحفيظ على المعان في المعاناه
والقتل طيب دعني اذهب الى رباط ساعود اليك
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه معنا الكاتب والناشط
الحقوقي احمد عصيد اهلا بك استاذ احمد
برايك هل شعور التعاطف هو شمولي كما يعني
تحدث منذ قليل الكتور نادر انه يعني هو
طبيعي لدى الانسان هل هو شمولي بالاساس ام
ان ويصبح انتقائي ام اننا يعني لا يمكن ان
يكون لدينا تعاط ف شموليا كبشر هو هو
تعاطف انتقائي بطبيعه الحال فعلا هذا
المفهوم للتضامن الانساني بالمعنى الكوني
الواسع هو مفهوم مرتبط بعصرنا لانه فيما
قبل المرحله التي نعيش فيها اليوم كان
الناس منغلقين اما في دول دينيه او في
قبائل او في مجموعات اثنيه لم تكن في كثير
من الاحيان تعلم عن بعضها البعض اي شيء
الا الرحال الذي الذي كانوا الذين كانوا
يقطعون الاف الكيلومترات ليكتشفوا ثقافات
وشعوب اخرى اليوم اصبح العالم كما يقال
قريه صغيره وشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
ووسائل الاعلام قربت بين الناس وتبلور
بالتالي مفهوم الانسان
بالمعنى الكوني منذ الاعلان عن المبادئ
الكبرى لحقوق الانسان منذ
48 اصبح المفهوم الكوني للانسان لكن له
جذور في فلسفه الانوار منذ القرن ال 18م ع
عندما كتب ايمانويل كانت بان الانسان
كرامه لانه غايه في ذاته ولا يمكن ان يكون
وسيله تقضى به اغراض اخرى منذ هذا التعريف
اصبح مفهوم التضامن الانساني يشمل كل
البشر باعتبار ان الانسان
جوهر يعني متعالي على الموجودات الاخرى
وبالتالي ينبغي ان تعطاه قيمته من حيث هو
انسان بغض النظر عن عقيدته او لونه او
عرقه او نسبه العائلي او لسانه ولغته او
اصله الى الى الى غير ذلك وطبعا التضامن
الانساني هنا ينبغي ان يجعلنا نتضامن مع
كل انسان مظلوم او كل انسان مقموع او كل
شعب محتل كيف ما كان في العالم بغض النظر
عن كل الاعتبارات لكن للاسف لا نزد هذا
والسبب في ذلك يعود الى التربيه من جهه
التي نتلقاها وتقوم اما على العقيده او
على العرقيه او نزعه قوميه معينه عندما
تطغى في المدرسه ووسائل الاعلام وفي
يعني الشبكات التبليغ والتواصل داخل
المجتمع فان الناس يضيق عندهم مفهوم
الانسان ويصبح هو الانسان في قوميتهم او
يصبح هو الانسان في عقيدتهم وهذا ما حدث
في دول شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط لقد تم
تضيق مفهوم الانسان ليختزل في الانسان
المسلم وليختزل ايضا في الانسان العربي
رغم ان العرب اقليه صغيره في هذه الخريطه
التي نتحدث عنها وطبعا برا سوف نجد بان
الذي تكلف في الدول العربيه لم يحصل في
مكان
اخر اه نعم خريطه شمال والشرق الاوسط الذي
نشر فكره ان
التضامن ينبغي ان يكون مع قوميه او مع
عقيده معينه هو
الايديولوجيات التي هيمنت في هذه الخريطه
لمده غير قصيره في التعليم وفي وسائل
الاعلام وهي ايديولوجيا القوميه العربيه
وا ايديولوجيا الاسلام السياسي طيب سنناقش
هذا الامر بعد قليل دعني فقط استمع الى
راي ضيفنا الاخير هنا في الاستديو المتخصص
في علم النفس السياسي وديناميكيات السرا
الكتور عماد موس اهلا بك دكتور عماد قبل
ان ندخل في صلب النقاش كيف يقارب علم
النفس شعور التعاطف وكيف يدخل هذا الشعور
عوالم السياسه شكرا ميسان اولا لازم نعرف
انه مساله التعاطف هي شيء فطري بالانسان
وحتى
بالحيوانات خلينا نتخيل مساله الاطفال
الرضع غالبا لما يبكوا الطفله الرضيع اللي
جنبه بيبكي مثله بالمقابل احيانا حتى في
عالم الحيوان لما يكون في هناك جرد في في
المصيده لجردان الاخر الاخريات يحاول
تخليصه من هذا المص مساعدته ف تعقيبا على
راي الضيف انه تعاطف اساسه التطور
البيولوجي اللي هو بالنهايه بنهايه المطاف
يهدف الى الابقاء على النوع وعلى الجنس
لانه التكاثف الاسري التكاثف المجتمعي
والحلقه الاكبر فالاكبر فالاكبر نعم وال
استمراريه الجنس نعم
اي المشكله بتحصل في لها عده عوامل
بالنسبه
للانتقائية اللي بنشوفه على التلفزيون
والتعاطف اللي بالنسبه لمقولات السياسيه
والسياسيين في بعد كبير جيوسياسي بهذا
الموضوع وارتباط مصالح ولكن وراء هذا كله
في شغله اسمها تشابه في القيم المتشابهات
القيميه بين بين الشخص و بينما نتعاطف مع
وهي بتكون متشابه في الثقافه في الدين في
الاثنيه في العرب يتعاطفون مع فلسطين
الاوروبين يتعاطفون مع اوكرانيا وهكذا
دويك الاساس في هذا هو مساله المراه ان
انا ارى نفسي بذات الشخص اللي انا متعاطف
معه العربي يرى نفسه اثنيا وثقافيا بمراه
الفلسطيني والعكس الاوروبي يرى نفسه بمراه
الاوكراني والعكس وبالتالي ه حتى لو لم
يكن هذا دقيقا او صحيحا او مطلقا في كل
الصراعات لا ما في شيء مطلق ابدا لما
نتكلم عن الامور ها
بتكلم المعدل العام ولكن هناك استثناءات
دائما وهذا سيسمى بالاستثمار العاطفي
عمليا لما نتكلم عن اشوف شخص احاول اتعاطف
معه وبالتالي انا استثمر عاطفيا تجاه هذا
الشخص وعندما يتعرض هذا الشخص للايذاء
النفسي او الجسدي هذا ينعكس علي سلبا
ينعكس علي حتى شعوريا ان يضع نفسي في
كانني اضع نفسي في مكان في مكانه طيب
وسياسيا هذا الامر كيف يدخل في السياسه
اليوم مس وراء السياسه في نفسيه في
سيكولوجيا غالبا احنا بنشوف الظاهر من هذا
الموضوع السياسيين بيتكلموا بامور قننوات
بس لازم نتذكر شغله معينه هون اول شيء
التعاطف غالبا رد فعل العاطفي وليس
بالضروره تحكيم
اخلاقي يعني تعقيبا على مساله الفيلسوف
الالماني مول كانت ان بيتكلم انه الشعور
بما يشعر الاخرين لا يعني صحه الحكم
الاخلاقي نعم شفنا الناس كثير متعاطفين
على سبيل المثال مع الحركه النازيه
وبالتالي في وقتها نعم في وقتها وفي
الامثله كثيره في الوقت الحالي ولكن
التعاطف السياسي معناه انه انا اخذ وجهه
نظر الاخر وجزء كبير منها حفاظا على اداه
في السياسه اداه ولكن وراءه محفز نفسي مش
دائما بالمطلق مش دائما بالمطلق انه بعض
الناس عندهم وعي ذاتي انهم قادرين انهم
يعملوا ريليشن يعني تنظيم للشعور العاطفي
اللي عندهم مثلا الاطباء ان الطبيب حاول
انه يخفض نسبه التعاطف عندهم من اجل ان
يستطيع يعني اداء وظيفته وال حيكون حجاب
من عينيه ولن يستطيع نعم الوظيفه ال
سياسيا ام س سنعود الى السياسه ولكن دعني
اسال ربما سمير عن هذا الامر يعني مساله
عندما ندخل اليوم هناك حديث لد كثير من
المفكرين وحتى في عالم الدبلوماسيه وعالم
السياسه على المستوى العالمي سمير عن بناء
تيارات التعاطف عن ان التعاطف اليوم يعني
بات انتقائيا او اكثر انتقائيه لانه ينظر
اليه كاداه ربما او يستخدم كاداه لدى لدى
الساسه ولدى القاده ولدى التيارات كما
تحدث منذ قليل ربما ايضا السيد احمد عصيد
من المغرب انه هناك بعض الايديولوجيات
ايضا التي بنت نوع من انواع التعاطف او من
التيارات التعاطف هل توافق على هذا الامر
هلا انا انظر الى الامر كما قلت سابقا من
وجهه نظر صحفي بحته يعني مثلا اذا اخذنا
بالملموس اذا تحدثنا عن
اوكرانيا كان هناك رغبه غربيه بتح يم
روسيا
والدعم الغربي للاوكرانيين كان عسكريا او
ماليا جاء بالدرجه الاولى من يعني لاسباب
جيو سياسيه بحته في الشارع بدا هناك تعاطف
غربي و يعني اقيمت مبادرات فرديه لمساعده
الاوكرانيين ولكن ما هو التعاطف يعني كيف
نحن ننظر الى المساله هذه المساله مساله
اوكرانيا او غزه بالنهايه في وسيله
في لكن هناك امور اخرى ايضا يعني سمير
هناك الزلازل يعني مثلا اعطي مثال ليس
ببعيد حصل زلزال المغرب وفي نفس الوقت حصل
فيضان في ليبيا وكان هناك ايضا مزايدات
حول مع من نتعاطف او تعاطفنا اكثر مع
هؤلاء وليس مع هؤلاء الضحايا وليس مع
اولئك الضحايا يعني هذا امر يتكرر في كل
العالم طيب يعني انت وصلت هذه الفكره ولكن
اريد ان اسال عن م انا فقط فقط اريد ان
اقول انه بالنهايه بالنهايه التعاطف كيف
يظهر تعاطف التعاطف الانساني مع اي ازمه
في العالم يظهر عبر الاعلام والاعلام في
في في مرحله صعبه جدا الاعلام بالنهايه
عنده راس المال عنده الدوله التي يعمل
فيها او يعمل لمصلحتها هناك المصالح وهناك
الجيو سياسه بالنهايه يعني اليوم مثلا نحن
نستقي اخبار غزه غالبا من وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لان لا ليس هناك من صحفيين يعني
هناك يمكن لا يمكن ان نقول هك هذا سمير
يعني هناك زملاء ايضا
يعملون طبعا هناك وكالات تعمل ولكن
التغطيه التغطيه يعني صعبه جدا اليوم عدد
الصحفي تصد على الميدان نعم طبعا طبعا
ميدانيا الوضع صعب جدا وبالتالي اي يعني
بالنهايه تصوير غزه تصوير ما يحدث في غزه
يعود بالدرجه الاولى للاعلام لان هذا
الامر هو الذي س سيسير او سيبني فكره لدى
الراي العام العالمي ام ولكن الوضع صعب
بصراحه من هذه الناحيه نعم هل يمكن ان
اتحدث عن راي عام عالمي في مساله التعاطف
وهذا كنت اريد ان اساله لك دكتور نادر
يعني اليوم هناك بعض بعض بعض المفكرين
الذين يعتبرون ان لا وجود لراي عام عالمي
هناك ربما
صراعات او او تيارات تساهم في بناء تعاطف
هنا او تكسر تعاطف هناك او هل هذا صحيح ام
لا ا طبعا انت تعرفي م مساله الراي العام
بشكل عام هي مرتبطه بما يسمى وسائل
الاعلام الجماهيريه يعني قبل وجود شيء
اسمه وسائل اعلام جماهيريه لا يوجد شيء
اسمه وسائل او راي عام حتى داخل المنطقه
الجغرافيه الصغيره يعني انا اسال على سبيل
المثال في بلد مثل مصر قبل ان توجد الصحف
والاذاعات والتلفزيونات وث لاحقا السوشيال
ميديا لو رجعنا الى بالزمن الى ما قبل
ثلاثه قرون كيف بامكان واحد يعيش في
الشمال ان يعرف ما يجري في في الجنوب حتى
يكون موقف او راي عام موحد بالتالي اللي
خلق الراي العام داخل البلدان وحتى مساله
الوحدات الوطنيه والاتحادات الوطنيه لها
دخل ايضا بوسائل الاعلام او ما يسمى
المجال العام ف وجود مجال عام عالمي وجود
وسائل الاعلام لديها قدره انتشار على
مستوى العالم هي اللي خلقت راي عام عالمي
وهذا الحقيقه مساله متاخره يعني مرتبطه
جديده ربما لا مرتبطه مرتبطه بتطور وسائل
الاعلام مق
المرشال مكلو نسميه وسائل الاعلام اللي
خلقت القريه الكونيه اللي هي الاذاعه
الاذاعه في البدايات
الاولى ثم لاحقا التلفزيون يعني نستطيع ان
نقارن على سبيل المثال بين الحروب التي
كانت تقع في العام 1800 والحرب العالميه
الثانيه لمن بدات الاذاعات في التوسع لم
بدات الصحف في التوسع والان لم بدات على
سبيل
المثال الحرب الاخيره او العدوان الاخير
على غزه في في راي عام كان موحد لكن الذي
حصل فعليا ان الراي العام العالمي الموحد
بدا يتجزا وجزء من التجز في الحقيقه
للمفارق يعني الاستاذ الكريم اللي تحدث
قبلي اشار الى اهميه وسائل السوشيال ميديا
في تلقي الاخبار بالوقت بحكم ان اغلب
وسائل الاعلام الجماهيريه التقليديه فعليا
محكومه لرؤوس اموال و متحيزه لاتجاهات
وتيارات سياسيه معينه نعم وبالتالي الحين
تتابع انت قناه فضائيه معينه توجهات
يمينيه و متحالفه مع الطرف
الالف انت فعليا تاخذ السرديه الف من من
القناه الفلانيه و تتجه لقناه اخرى تاخذ
سرديه اخرى وبالتالي عليك ان تذهب
للسوشيال ميديا لترى مختلف وجهات النظر
حتى تكون
التص الموقف تبحث عنه لكن سوشيال ميديا
فعليا الفيسبوك الانستغرام
التويتر او الاكس هو احد الادوات المعاول
الاساسيه لتفكيك الراي العام الموحد ام
بمعنى سابقا كانوا الناس يتجهون الى قناه
فضائيه واحده او اذاعه واحده او صحيفه
واحده او اكثر قليلا لكن الان هناك حسابات
بالملايين فانت تتابع من وتترك من طيب ففي
تجزء حصل في السوشيال ميديا الامر الاخر
في راي عام قابل للتلفيق في السوشيال
ميديا بمعنى هناك حسابات اخبار كاذبه هناك
طبعا اكيد هناك ليس فقط اخبار كاذبه هناك
حسابات غير صح صحيحه يعني حسابات مزيفه
وجدت اساسا لخلق راي عام مزيف او مفبرك
ففي مشكله في في نوع من البروباجندا ربما
الحديثه التي تجري على على الرغم من هذا
على الرغم من هذا الحقيقه اللي يتابع ما
يجري في العالم خلال ال 45 الفائته يلاحظ
ان هناك حمله او حركه تعاطف وتضامن عام
واسع تمتد من واشنطن ونيويورك الى لندن
الى حتى طوكيو فضلا المنطقه العربيه في في
في تضامن بالرغم من المشكلات اللي تواجه
وسائل الاعلام التقليديه
والتجزيء رغم هذا المشهد هناك ارتفاع في
في في في مستوى التعاطف او التضامن لدى
لدى الناس مع المشاكل طيب ولكن اريد ان ان
اسال ربما استاذ احمد عصيد لا ادري ان كنت
توافق على هذا النقاش
رايتك غير موافق
ربما لا لا لا طبعا
من الصعب يعني بناء راي عام عالمي في
الخريطه الدوليه الموجوده الان بسبب
الصراعات بين الدول وتضارب المصالح ولهذا
لا يوجد راي عام عالمي موحد حول القضيه
هذا من جانب من جانب اخر صحيح ان وسائل
الاعلام تكيف الوعي المواطن في كل بلد
عندما تهيمن وتؤكد على فكره معينه يوميا
تمطر الناس يوميا بصوره معينه تترسخ هذه
الصوره في الاذان لكن لا ينبغي ان ننسى
المدرسه المدرسه شيء اساسي جدا لانها
تتعلق بالتنشئه الاجتماعيه للاطفال منذ سن
السادسه وهذا يخلق
يوتيب يخلق صور نمطيه كما يخلق كذلك
تصورات معينه وهذا يساهم فيما بعد عندما
يكبر الانسان على ان يتخذ مواقف لصالح هذا
الطرف او لصالح هذا بالنسبه للمسيرات التي
التي وجدت في العالم من اجل القضيه
الفلسطينيه وفي دعم غزه والشعب الفلسطيني
هي مسيرات انسانيه من منطلق التضامن
الانساني يعني الناس في امريكا لا
يتضامنون لان القتلى عرب ولا ان القتلى
مسلمون بل يتضامنون مع الفلسطينيين كضحايا
للقصف الاسرائيلي و وهذا هو التضامن
الانسان يعني لو يقع نفس الشي
يعني هو اه لو يقع نفس الشيء في بلد اخر
سيتم نفس يعني الموقف لكن عندنا نحن في
شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط هذا غير موجود
هذا التضامن الانساني وساعطيكم مثالا في
دارفور قتل 300 الف مواطن واحرقوا بالنار
وتم تهجير مليونين من البشر من طرف مجرم
الحرب عمر البشير وادانته المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
ولم يحرك احد ساكنا كما لو ان هؤلاء ذباب
او حشرات وليسوا بشر ولكن هذا هذا تساؤل
تجد على الانترنت عنوانه التضامن الانساني
والتضامن العرقي وهذا المقال ادنت فيه هذا
الصمت وطرحت السؤال هل هؤلاء الناس حشرات
وطبعا
عندما يموت فلسطينيون الشوارع كلها في في
شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط تخرج طبعا
ينبغي التضامن مع الشعب الفلسطيني لان
هناك احتلال وهناك ظلم وهناك مستوطنات
وعنصريه نعم
ولكن ينبغي ايضا التضامن مع اي انسان في
اي هل هذا ممكن ظلم قتل ظلما اليوم هناك
هناك هناك ايضا اجهاد التعاطف على ما يبدو
يعني ان التعاطف لدى
البشر حسب حسب العديد من من ال من
ال يعني الدراسات التي تمت ان اننا احيانا
نتعاطف مع افراد اكثر مما نتعاطف مع مصائب
تصيب مجموعات مثلا يعني ممكن ان نتعاطف مع
طفل قتل اكثر من نتعاطف مع مجموعه اطفال
قتلوا في ان معا يعني هناك العديد من
الدراسات التي يعني دراسات علم النفس طبعا
ولكن هناك امر ايضا اضافي اريد ان اسال
عنه مساله شكل المجتمعات التي بدنا نعيش
بها اليوميه مجتمعات مستهلكه ارتفعت في
فردنا ربما الى حد
كبير تحدث استاذ احمد عصيد عن امر مهم جدا
انه التعاطف الانتقائي وهذا ما نناقشه
نتعاطف مع هذه المجموعه ولكن لا نفكر مثلا
هذا التليفون من الذي يصنعه هل هناك اطفال
يصنعون ملابسنا يتم استعبادهم بشكل او
باخر في في في العمل لا تدفع لهم اجور
يعملونه قصر عماد لماذا اليوم نحن يعني
نفسيا كيف تفسر هذا الامر
اول شي اول شيء اللي حكى فيه الدكتور هو
يعني منطقي جدا في مساله اسمها الاكسبوجر
اللي هو التعرض او
الرؤيه حاليا حضرتك طرحتي مساله اللي بعدش
التعاطف مع الافراد وليس مع الجمعات لانه
الجمعات ليس لها لا لون ولا طعم ولا ولا
شكل ولا مشاعر ولا فردانيه وبالتالي ككتله
واحده صعب التعاطف مع صعب التماهي معها
ولكن عندما نفكك هذه الجماعات تصبح لها
اسماء تصبح افراد تصبح تصبح لها يعني
احلام عمليا كافراد وبالتالي انا قصص يصبح
يعني من فرد على فرد اسهل على الانسان انه
يتعاطف يعني عمليا يعني من منطلق يعني
تعرض معين كنت اتعامل كثير معه صحفيين
كانوا بيشتغلوا في في اسرائيل على سبيل
المثال كانوا ينتقلوا للعمل في غزه
المنظور السياسي تبعهم كان يتغير يعني 360
درجه تماما لما يتعاملوا مع الش الشعب
الفلسطيني شخص كشخص هي السرديه التكتل
المجموعه تتفكك تصبح اشخاص وبالتالي انا
كشخص قادر على التعاطف مع هذا مع هذا
الانسان الفر مع الفرد اكثر من تعاطفي مع
مجموعه او قضيه او لان انا كانسان ارى
انعكاسي بصوره شخص اخر وليس بصوره جماعه
نعم سمير توافق يعني اليوم هناك حملات
كثيره انت يعني بصفاتك ايضا صحفي شاهدت
عليها ربما هذا يعني هذه الح التي تجري
اليوم في في
غزه اعادت مساله لنضع اسماء على صور
الضحايا ان من الجانب الاسرائيلي او من
الجانب الفلسطيني اليوم هل الفرد يؤثر
اكثر هل قصه الفرد تؤثر اكثر في مساله
التعاطف بصراحه ممكن ل للشعوب الغربيه
مثلا ان تؤدي الى حد ما يعني ان تشكل ضغطا
على حكوماتها الى الى ما يعني الى لاي
حدود هذا الامر لا احد يمكن ان يجيب عليه
يعني حتى الساعه لان المدافع تتحدث الان
اي المهم او بالاحرى يعني ما حدث في غزه
مرعب مرعب لاسباب عده اولا لان ما حدث في
7 اكتوبر يعني قامت بها مجموعه حماس اللي
هي مجموعه اسلاميه ونعرف جيدا ان العالم
منذ هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر العالم
الغربي خائف جدا يخاف جدا من هذه الحركات
المتشدده الاسلاميه تحدث عن المجتمعات
الغربيه طبعا وبالتالي حكومات هذه
المجتمعات
يعني يعني انا لا اعرف اذا كانت بالنتيجه
عمليه حماس مش لا اعرف انا برايي انه
عمليه حماس في السابع من اكتوبر يعني جلبت
الدمار والاذيه الى الفلسطينيين اكثر مما
ساعدتهم هذا في الدرجه الاولى رد الفعل
الغربي ممكن ان يخضع
لمعايير عده رد الفعل السياسي مؤيد
لاسرائيل بشكل عام حتى لو صوتت فرنسا
لصالح القرار البرازيلي في مجلس انا لا
اريد ان اغرق كثيرا في هذا الملف يعني في
السياسه طبعا طبعا ولكن و ما اريد ما اريد
قوله ان التعاطف الشعبي التعاطف الشعبي
ممكن ان يؤثر على السلطه السياسيه الى حد
معين ولكن الى اي الى ايه حدود لا اعرف
لانه السلطه السياسيه بالنهايه عندها
حساباتها وهي بتشوف ماذا هناك على الارض
هناك هناك ح سالتك سمير عن انسنت الضحايا
عن مساله انه عندما تتحول عندما نتحول من
مجموعه من الضحايا الى ضحيه وهذا ايضا
يعني في عملنا هذا هذه الصوره رايناها مع
مع الطفل الغريق ايلان لا اعرف ان كنت على
شواطئ شواطئ اوروبا الجنوبيه راينا هذه
ال نعم التي تصبح فايرل والتي تؤدي الى
موجات كبيره من التعاطف ولكن انا عندي
نظره خاصه بالسوشال ميديا ايضا هي ان
السوشال ميديا يعني السوشيال ميديا نوع من
كموجه يبدا التعاطف وبعد فتره معينه اسبوع
اسبوعين ثلاثه اسابيع تنتهي الامور فيما
تستمر الماساه على ارض الواقع وبالتالي
يعني التعاطف يعني التعبير عن التعاطف هو
شيء ايجابي وانساني ولكن هل هل فعلا يؤدي
الى نتيجه العمل السياسي هو الذي يؤدي الى
نتيجه الدبلوماسيه هي التي تؤدي الى نتيجه
هذا رايي وانا راي واقعي جدا يعني اعرف
كنت اتمنى العالم ان يكون مختلفا للاسف
العالم يعني منه مؤسسه خيريه طيب عندي
سؤال عندي سؤال يعني اليوم ساسال دكتور
نادر وهو يعني احيانا ننظر الى شخصين في
نفس الحاله
يعني انسان هنا وانسان هناك ماتى بنفس
الطريقه ولكن نرى ان التعاطف يحصل بشكل
مختلف وغير متكافئ مع ضحيتين سقطتا بنفس
الطريقه او بنفس الاس اسلوب هل الحروب
تغير في هذا الامر هل الصراعات السياسيه
تغير في هذا الامر ام الموضوع يبدا كما
قال سيد عصيد منذ البدايه منذ تنشئه
الانسان الشخص
كانسان طبعا التنشئه تلعب دور كبير في هذا
الموضوع ولكن ليس فقط التنشئه يعني هذا
امر او عامل غير غير كافي
لحاله طبعا انت تعرف العباره الشائعه الحب
يعمي ويصم ايضا الكره يعمي ويصم فعليا ال
درجه المسافه فضلا عن درجه العداوه اللي
تجعلنا احيانا نجرد البشر من انسانيتهم
نعم يعني فعليا افتقاد التعاطف مع فرد
معين وتوجيه التعاطف لفرد اخر مرتبط
بالدرجه الاساس بتجريد الطرف الاول من
انسانيته والتعامل معه احيانا على ان هو
حشره او حيوان او حتى شيء من الاشياء يعني
شفنا التصريحات البعض المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين ان هؤلاء الفلسطينيين ليسوا
بشرا هؤلاء حيوانات بل هم اق ربما خوف من
التعاطف مع الذي يعتبر عدوا يعني حتى لو
الانسان يعني الى حد ما تجرد من مواقفه
السياسيه وحاول ان ينظر الى الاخر كانسان
هل يمكن ان يخاف لانه يتعاطف مع طرف يعتبر
او يعتبره حتى هو عدو لا بالعكس هو هو
فعليا هو تحقيق لانسانه ان يتعاطف مع
انسان اخر يتالم ويعاني لكن المشكله لا
تكمن هنا المشكله ان سياقات العداء سياقات
الكراهيه الحاده في تحديدا اوقات الحروب
لا تسمح اصلا بوجود هذا النوع من التعاطف
او التشلر يعني اذا اذا تصورنا التعاطف ا
اشبه بغرفه ذات ابواب تفتح وتغلق انت
تفتحها في لحظات معينه وتغلقها في لحظات
اخرى نعم يعني يعني هناك تفضل الفرق بين
معاناه يتعرض لها ضحيه في كارثه طبيعيه
على سبيل المثال ام على سبيل المثال حصل
الزلزال وتعرض مجموعه بشر الى وتحولوا الى
ضحايا ام هذا موضوع مختلف عنما يحصل في
لحظات الحروب لان الحروب عاده تكون مصحوبه
بخلق وتاجي الكراهيات الجماعيه والعداوات
الجماعيه وبالتالي
استحضارها استحضارها للواجهه في نوع من
التاجج للمشاعر وال بشكل حاد في نوع من
استقطاب مشاعر يحصل نعم وبالتالي يحصل هذا
النوع من التعاطف الانتقائي اللي قد لا
يوجد في لحظات الزلازل الطبيعيه مع العلم
ان الكثير من الكوارث الطبيعيه احيانا
يكون سببها الانسان او اطراف معينه موجوده
يعني يمكن ان تحاسب
عليها ولا احد يعني ينظر اليها
ككارثة تمثل التعاطف المطلق يعني مع كل
الضحايا في كل
العالم واجبها ان لا تفرق بين الضحايا هي
هنا
لتستنشق وقعت كارثه في اي مكان اوكي ولكن
اليوم يعني هذه المؤسسات باتت للاسف
الشديد نكته في عيون الكثير من الناس في
مساله التعاطف بالتحديد لماذا برايك هو
اولا بالنسبه لمؤسسات المجتمع المدني
مؤسسات الامم المتحده المساله غير قائمه
على التعاطف كرجال عاطفي ولكنها قائمه على
قوانين معينه خاضعه
للمنطق والتقنين الا والتقنين الاخلاقي
عموما اللي تكلمت فيه ب بعد اللحظه انه
التعاطف رد فعل وبالتالي غير مرتبط
بالضروره بالاخلاق اي
ولكن لما عندما يخرج امين العام للامم
المتحده على سبيل المثال يدين القصف
الاسرائيل في غزه يتهم يشيطن من اسرائيل
عندما يتهم حماس بارتكاب مثلا جرائم
ام المسه هنا مثل ما حكور مت بالشحن
العاطفي
نفي ها الفرق بين هاي وبين الظواهر
الطبيعيه انه في في سياق الحروب هناك
طرفين ابيض واسود يجب ان تاخذ يعني لا
يمكن لشخص ان يكون لديه موقف سياسي بدون
ان يكون لديه تعاطف
انتقائي ممكن ان تكون مع قضيه ما وان تكون
متعاطف مع الجميع مع الضحيه ومع يعني هناك
الضحيه ضحيه الضحيه المظلومه وايضا هناك
ضحيه احيانا تقع من ناحيه الظالم فهل يمكن
ان يحصل هذا الامر خلينا نفهم شغله
التعاطف مثل ما هو قوه جباره بتدفع للناس
للتكاثر واستمراريه الجنس البشري ولكن
بالمقابل ممكن تكون قوه مدمره بمعنى انه
عندما يكون التعاطف منكفئ على الذات في في
حاله القوميات والايديولوجيات وبالتالي
تصبح شيء يعني ما يسمى بالانانيه الجمعيه
اي نرجع مره ثانيه نقتبس من الحروب وغيره
مثلا على سبيل المثال الايدولوجيا
الصهيونيه قائمه على مبدا انه نحن موجودون
من اجل محاربه فناء الجنس اليهودي مره
اخرى وبالتالي اي تهديد موجود بالنسبه
للصهيونيه يعتبر تهديد وجودي وفي بالتالي
بعمق الانكفاء على الذات اي شيء اسرائيل
بتقوم بفعله يعتبر رد فعل الدفاع عن الذات
هذا هو المنطق ولكن ولكن بالمقابل هذ
يصاحبه تجييش والتجييش
يحتاج يوجه الى الداخل و ما دام كل الطاقه
العاطفيه في الداخل فكل ما شيء الطرف
الاخر يصبح مشيط وبالتالي لانه يعتبر
تهديد وجود لهذا الطرف هي مره ثانيه
محاوله الحفاظ على الذات نعم حمايه الذات
حمايه الذات يعني التعاطف ايضا مستمل طيب
سيد عصيد تفضل عندك تعليق على على ما دار
من
حديث نعم فيما يتعلق بكون الضالم احيانا
عندما يكون ضحيه هل يستوجب ايضا التعاطف
نعم بالطبع اذا كان ما حدث له غير مقبول
مثل ما حدث يوم 7 اكتوبر انا شخصيا قلت
انما فعلته حماس ليس مقاومه بل لان قتل
شباب في مهرجان
للموسيقى ليس مقاومه المقاومه هي مواجهه
جيش الاحتلال ومواجهه القوى الامنيه
للاحتلال
وعندما يصرخ الناس اليوم يقولون ان
اسرائيل تقتل المدنيين فحماس ايضا قتلت
المدنيين اذا علينا ان يكون لنا موقف
متوازن انساني نحن ضد هل يمكن ان تكون مع
قضيه وان تكون
متوازن يعني هل يكون هل يمكن ان تكون مثلا
مع قضيه مثل القضيه الفلسطينيه او مثلا مع
قضيه مثل قضيه التخلص من العبوديه وان
تكون متوازن اذاء الطرف الاخر الذي يعني
يتهم بالظلم او يتهم بارتكاب
الظلم لا لا المقاومه حق لكل شعب محتل هذا
المبدا العام ولكن هناك كما قال الاستاذ
اخلاقيات وهذه الاخلاقيات ايضا ينبغي ان
تحترم فطلاق الرصاص بشكل عشوائي على شباب
في مهرجان للموسيقى ليس من افعال المقاومه
وهذا جلب الكثير من السخط الدولي على حماس
وهو الان يجلب نفس الشيء لنفس السبب يجلب
سخط دولي على اسرائيل لانها ايضا تقتل
المدنيين ووصلت الى
12000 قتيل فبالنسبه لي شخصيا اعتقد انه
في تربيه النشء ينبغي ان يكون هناك توازن
بين زرع الحس الانساني والفكره الانسيه
يعني
الانيم وبين جعل الخصوصيات الثقافيه
الدينيه والقوميه ملكيه للبشريه جمعاء
واعتقد ان هذا هو ما ينقص بلدان شمال
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط فهم
يضعون المكونات الدينيه والقوميه كما لو
انها مضاده لما هو انساني او لما هو كوني
ونحن في هذه الايام مثلا نقوم بمراجعه
مدونه الاسره في المغرب وهناك من يستعمل
الدين ضد حقوق المراه بصفتها انسان فهنا
نصدم ما هو خصوصي بما هو كوني وهذا نتاج
تربيه خاطئ في ال طيب دكتور نادر تعقيب
على ما تفضل به الاستاذ احمد لو سمحت يعني
كلمه اخيره لك في هذا الصدد اليوم هل يمكن
ان نقول ان ان الانسانيه يمكن ان تسقط
احيانا ضحيه التعاطف
الانتقائي لا هي ساقطه اصلا في في هذا
الموضوع لكن انا فقط الفت
انتباه المشاهدين الى مساله ان لماذا
ترتبط الحروب او لحظات الحروب الاهليه
والمواجهات والتصادمات اللي فيها
طرفين جلاد ضحيه بمساله نزع انسانيه
الضحيه نعم بمساله تصوير الطرف الاخر على
ان هو حيوان ولا ان هو كلب ولا انه حشره
وانه خنزير وانه كذا و حتى الحيوانات لها
حقوق يعني ولا ولا ولا يمكن قتلها يعني
انا انا انا بديت مداخلته الاولى بالاشاره
الى جنج ك روسو لان روسو كان يقول بان
التعاطف او الشفقه ليس فقط قانون طبيعي
انساني هو قانون طبيعي تجاه اي كائن يحس
يشعر بالالم قالتي لانه واحد من ابرز
المزايا لدى كلكل البشر التعاطف لدى كل
البشر حتى تجاه الحيوانات ب انا لا اتحمل
ان ارى ان امامي مثلا خيلا
يذبح بهذا الشكل بس هذا ايضا لا لا لا لا
يبعد مساله التعاطف الانتقائي لان انا لا
اتحمل ان ارى خيلا يذبح امامي لكني لا
امانع ان ادعس نمله على سبيل المثال تمام
السبب مرتبط بمساله الى اي درجه انا اشعر
بالقرب مع هذا الكائن شكرا لك دكتور نادر
هل يعني الانسانيه هي ضحيه التعاطف
الانتقائي احيانا قال دكتور نادر هي يعني
ضحيه بشكل هل توافق اليوم وقت بسس من جان
جا كروسو ان هذا ينطبق على كل البشر وهذا
بعلم النفس غير حقيقي لانه مش كل البشر ق
نفس القدره على التعاطف الناس اللي
بيعانوا من العضال النفسي او اضطراب
الشخصيه النرجسيه هم القادرين على ارتكاب
جرائم بدون الشعور بالذنب نعم لدرجه معين
وبالتالي هي بينقب على تقريبا 2% من البشر
سيد احمد عصيد بعدك معنا كلمه ختاميه لو
سمحت في مساله التعاطف الانتقائي كلمه
ختاميه اتمنى اتمنى
ان تصبح بؤر التوتر اماكن للتلاقي الحضاري
وان لا يفقد الانسان الحكمه التي جعلته
يسعى الى التعارف مع الاخر ويتبادل معه
حضاريا وثقافيا و ودينيا وتجاريا واتمنى
ايضا ان يصبح عالمنا عالم ا اكثر استعدادا
لتقبل الجميع بالصفه الانسانيه شكرا لك
وشكرا لكل ضيوف النقاش في فلك الممنوع لا
نهايه له نترك لك ولك حريه التفكير وحريه
الاختيار الى اللقاء في حلقات جديده دائما
على شاشه فرونس ك وعلى اثير اذاعه
مونتكارلو الدوليه
تحياتي